اثار مقطع فيديو متداول لخطابي كمال
هيرريس نائبه الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن في
البيت الابيض جدلا واسعا كانت تتحدث
وتتصرف بشكل غريب للوهله الاولى كان من
الواضح انها كانت تعاني من نوبه هل على
المسرح او على الاقل تكافح من اجل الحفاظ
على تماسكها فيما توقعت وسائل اعلام بانها
ربما كانت تحت تاثير الكحول في حين شبهها
البعض بها ثوره وخطوات الرئيس بايدن
[موسيقى]
يوجد
[ضحك]
[موسيقى]
انتشر ايضا على مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي
مقطع فيديو يظهر الرئيس التركي رجب طيب
اردوغان وهو يوجه صفعه صغيره الى وجه طفل
كان يقف الى جانبه في مركز اقتراع خلال
ادلائه بصوته في الانتخابات التركيه وتبين
ان الطفل الذي كان الى جانب اردوغان هو
حفيده وقد جاءت الصفعه في اطار المزاح
مقطع فيديو متداول اثار الذعر في اليابان
حيث اظهر الفيديو خطوطا ناريه شوهدت في
سماء جنوب البلاد السلطات فسرت الامر بانه
قد يكون ناجما عن حطام صاروخ اطلته الصين
[موسيقى]
ضجه مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي في تركيا
بفيديو وثقوا مشهدا غريبا لسياره تبتلعها
حفره وسط الطريق بسبب السيول الغزيره التي
شاهدتها
شهدتها مدينه انقره فيما لم يتبين في
المقطع ما اذا كان هنالك احد داخل السياره
اثناء غرقها
[موسيقى]
كان هذا كل شيء لليوم لمتابعه المزيد من
الاخبار والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه
والوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط
على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات